the neglected tropical diseases are
diseases which as you can tell by their
name are terribly neglected it means
that they have not received the level of
interest or investment or intervention
that they deserve over the years and yet
by some estimates they actually are the
together the largest disease burden on
the planet today so one of the most
common diseases of the neglected
tropical diseases are intestinal worms
and these are worms which embed
themselves in the bowel they can result
in malnutrition they can result in
vitamin deficiencies they can result in
diarrhea and ultimately making children
and adults as well more susceptible to
other diseases and I think that this is
a really important takeaway on the NTDs
as they're called the neglected tropical
diseases some of them appear to actually
be linked to other diseases recent data
just out in the past couple of months
shows that one of these entities
schistosomiasis can raise the rate of
HIV AIDS infection by threefold in women
well how does that happen
schistosomiasis is a particularly
pernicious disease carried by snails and
the parasite can actually result in
vaginal lesions which make a woman more
likely to contract HIV AIDS during
sexual intercourse so preventing these
diseases and treating these diseases is
critical well what does it take to treat
them we already know that it costs
between 35 and 50 cents for well-known
treatments many of which are available
by donation to treat kids and to treat
adults for these diseases but treatment
alone is not the answer what what else
is needed is actually access to clean
water basic hygiene and sanitation and
basic hygienic practices in order to
avoid the transmission of these entities
in the first place this is probably one
of the areas of global health where we
can have the most bang for our buck a
lot of people are extremely critical of
vertical solutions just focusing on one
disease or another disease but in the
case of neglected tropical disease
this is something that can be done
through schools it can be done through
existing health centers there's not a
massive incremental cost it doesn't take
a lot more time to do and yet it
actually has a domino effect on taking
out other diseases downstream and
overall improving lives and improving
productivity